In this lesson I'll be
talking about focus and
how you can manage it
in your application.
Now in a nutshell, focus refers to
the control on the computer screen that
receives input from the keyboard and
from the clipboard when you paste.
You're probably familiar with focus for
text fields.
In order to type in a text field you
first have to go over with your mouse
and click on it.
Well that act of clicking on the text
field, that's actually what focuses it.
You may also know that if you then press
the tab key it will then move focus to
the next text field or
available control.
Now some users drive the computer
entirely with the keyboard or
some other type of
discrete input device.
For those users,
focus is absolutely critical.
It's their primary means of
reaching everything on the screen.
And so for that reason the Web AIM
checklist states in section 2.1.1,
that all page functionality should
be available using the keyboard,
unless it's something you couldn't
normally do with a keyboard like free
hand drawing or something like that.
So this is a great place to start
learning about accessibility because
obviously we all know
how to use a keyboard.
It's very easy to relate to and
test, and
it benefits virtually all of our users.
There's users out there with motor
impairments which could be caused by
anything from paralysis or
even just a broken arm.
Those folks may be relying on a keyboard
or switch device to navigate your page,
so a good focus strategy is going
to be absolutely critical for them.
And for the power users out there,
those folks who know every keyboard
shortcut on their machine and
hate having to use the mouse, well,
for them, being able to navigate, for
instance, a form on your site, is just
going to make them more productive.
So well-implemented focus strategy
means everyone using your application
will have a better experience.
And as we'll see in
the next few lessons,
the work that we do today on focus
is actually an important primer for
supporting assistive technology users.